patrick jakob hier aber wo ist
eigentlich hier nun das ist natürlich
eine frage mit vielen
antwortmöglichkeiten wenn du meinst wo
wir uns gerade befinden nun wir sind
jetzt gerade in köln ehrenfeld nrw
deutschland auf dem planeten erde das
sagst du so einfach aber wusstest du
dass unser komplettes bild von der erde
verzehrt ist jede 2d karte die du jemals
gesehen hat ist eigentlich falsch
grönland ist nicht so groß wie es auf
der karte aussieht und kanada ist zwar
groß aber auch nicht größer als afrika
warum alle karten falsch sind das
erklären wir auf dem kanal von jakob
breaking lab das video verlinkt sich am
ende von diesem video hier video hier
sag mal jakob sind wir gerade in einem
video sind wir auf diesem bildschirm
gefangen na ja wir sind mit einem video
aber ist dass hier gerade das video sind
wir nicht einfach nur daten die zu einem
endgerät geschickt werden
die eigentliche frage müsste lauten wo
ist das internet wo ist das video
gespeichert in dem wir gerade drin
stecken
naja das internet ist fast überall
kupfer und glasfaser leitungen liegen
zwar nur auf bestimmten strecken aber
das funknetz direkt zum beispiel über 90
prozent aller menschen weltweit ab aber
das internet ist ja nicht nur eine
verbindung von milliarden von geräten
das internet ist auch daten und die
daten die du jetzt gerade sie ist dieses
video hier die liegen auf den servern
von youtube bzw
google bzw alfabet aber wo die server
genau stehen das ist gar nicht so leicht
zu beantworten wo dieses video jetzt
gerade ist kann man nicht genau wissen
denn google bewahrt über so etwas
extremes stillschweigen und es gibt
mehrere server auf denen dieses video
jetzt gerade liegen kann es gibt sowohl
server in den niederlanden als auch
belgien als auch dänemark aber da haben
wir es doch hier ist entweder in belgien
niederlanden oder dänemark
aber so einfach ist es nicht daten
werden auf großen servern nicht einfach
abgespeichert den festplatten können
kaputt gehen zum beispiel durch vier
benutzung oder über die jahre
deshalb werden videos aufgeteilt
durch komplizierte mathematik müssen
videos aber nicht doppelt und dreifach
gespeichert werden sondern können
aufgeteilt werden und wieder hergestellt
werden geht ein server kaputt heißt es
man kann die daten noch hätten einfach
mit dem anderen server mit den dateien
die dort gespeichert sind
und generell wird es so sein dass
youtube dieses video hier auf vielen
verschiedenen servern speichert bedeutet
das dass wir gerade zerstückelt sind es
kann gut sein dass wir das schon immer
waren auch auf normalen festplatten
werden große dateien teilweise in
fragmenten gespeichert zum beispiel
wurde einer datei vorher auf dieser
festplatte gelöscht kann es sein dass
das video wieder einzelne lücken füllt
und so ist auch das video dann
zerstückelt nun wenn man schon dieses
video nicht genau verorten kann dann
noch sicherlich mich oder ich bin hier
aber wo bin ich eigentlich genau bin ich
hier
oder vielleicht hier die meisten
menschen würden wahrscheinlich sagen
dass ich dass ich hier befindet aber bin
ich wirklich nur ein glitschiger haufen
der sich in einem knochen schädel
befindet wo ist mein bewusstsein nun
eine menge informationen verarbeiten wir
in der großhirnrinde
hier liegen zum beispiel der primäre
visuelle kortex und der primäre
akustische cortex aber auch der
assoziations cortex befindet sich in der
großhirnrinde der ist entscheidend für
dinge die aufmerksamkeit motivation
kreativität und sogar soziale normen
generell kann man sagen dass die
großhirnrinde ein zentraler ort für das
bewusstsein ist hier werden
entscheidungen getroffen erinnerungen
gespeichert und pläne für die zukunft
gemacht dinge die essenziell sind wenn
wir vom thema bewusstsein sprechen
aber wie so oft wenn es um das gehirn
geht stimmt das nicht 100 prozentig ohne
andere teile des gehirns könnte die
großhirnrinde das alles gar nicht machen
alles um gehören ist miteinander
verbunden
viele teile des gehirns arbeiten
zusammen teilen sich aufgaben oder
machen dinge die wir heute noch gar
nicht verstehen und selbst wenn wir
einen bereich für das ich irgendwo im
gehirn festlegen könnten
sind es nicht sowieso meine gedanken
also die elektrochemischen impulse
zwischen den neuronen die mich zu mir
machen bin ich also nur die art und
weise wie meine neuronen miteinander
verbunden sind bin ich eigentlich ein
bereich und gar keinen punkt ab wann
wird eigentlich einen bereich zu einem
punkt und wie klein können wir da gehen
mehr kommen
ich bin gerade eine bank aber eigentlich
geht es um max planck max planck hat die
kleinste länge definiert unter der die
physikalischen gesetze die wir bis jetzt
kennen gelten die planck länge ist so
klein dass jedes materielle objekt was
kleiner ist direkt zu einem schwarzen
loch kollabieren würde und sie ist zehn
hoch 20 mal kleiner als der durchmesser
von einem proton und damit eigentlich
das kleinste was wir kennen sozusagen
das was einem punkt am nächsten schlauch
rolle gepäck schlauch rolle wacht das
sind die drei worte die zu genau diesem
ort hier passen
wordpress.com hat die ganze welt in ein
3 meter mal 3 meter großes netz an
quadrate unterteilt und jedem einzelnen
quadrat eine bestimmte kombination aus
orten zugeordnet
die idee dahinter ist dass man sich eine
kombination aus drei worten viel
einfacher merken kann als eine lange
zahlenkombination wie zum beispiel bei
gps koordinaten
natürlich ist unser gpf ganz gut darin
zu erkennen wo wir gerade auf der erde
sind doch unsere erde bewegt sich mit
30.000 metern die sekunde um unsere
sonne und unser sonnensystem
das bewegt sich mit 220 kilometern die
sekunde um das zentrum der milchstraße
und unsere galaxie bewegen sich mit 1000
kilometer in der sekunde auf den großen
attraktor zu das heißt hier ist jetzt
ein anderer ort als jetzt genau und es
kommen noch krasser weil unser universum
das dient sich auch immer weiter aus und
zwar immer schneller
was ziemlich überraschend für viele
physikerinnen und physiker war
na ja und warum das wissen wir nicht so
genau aber wir vermuten dass es an der
dunklen energie
wow aber woraus expandiert das universum
und wo expandiert es hin
nun ja überall hin wenn wir uns andere
galaxien angucken zum beispiel mit dem
hubble weltraumteleskop dann sehen wir
dass sich beinahe alle diese galaxien
von uns entfernen das licht das uns von
diesen galaxien erreicht ist rot
verschulden das bedeutet dass die
lichtwellen durch die expansion des
universums in die länge gezogen wurden
daraus kann man berechnen wie schnell
sich diese galaxien von uns entfernen
und wenn man zurück rechnet dann kommt
man zu dem schluss dass sich vor 13,8
milliarden jahren
alles an einem punkt gefunden hat das
ist der zeitpunkt an dem der urknall
passiert ist aber wo ist der urknall
passiert nun er sieht so aus als würde
sich jetzt gerade alles von uns
entfernen
sind wir also das zentrum ist die erde
der mittelpunkt des universums
der urknall ist hier passiert aber auch
überall sonst im universum
egal wo man sich befindet es sieht so
aus als würden sich die galaxien von
einem entfernen
in der andromeda galaxie überall in der
wexstraße überall auf der erde und eben
auch hier
hier ist überall aber hier ist nicht
hier auf der weltkarte den alle welt
karten sind falsch und ihr seht ihr
wieso denn auf dem kanal von jacobs
tracking lab haben wir wieder zusammen
gemacht wo wir es an den drei die
weltkarte eine 2 die weltkarte gemacht
haben und dabei die erde zerschnitten
haben nach einem klick darauf ja